[Music]
and totally not suspicious news
submitted by Tupac is alive I believe
that me to a military agency made a
strange public request they got everyone
nervous
what are they saying what country um
Taiwan Taiwan was what they like hey
guys it's time for us to be independent
from China and we're like whoo oh no no
no no no no no they were like we're
gonna stop serving stinky tofu no like
oh no no you can't even that's
blasphemous you went there the US
government burger a US government agency
which is the Defense Advanced Research
Projects Agency which is DARPA they
tweeted is that the drone companies they
designed the internet and should go
they're the ones that they say there are
like 50 years ahead of whatever
technology we have now they're the ones
that also brought stealth weaponry the
m16 assault rifle military drones Wow
the computer mouse and theory and other
things in the internet okay so this is a
different look they have a special
agreement with aliens oh yeah oh they
tweeted this oh I'm sure attention city
dwellers we're interested in identifying
university-owned or commercially managed
underground urban tunnels and facilities
able to host research and
experimentation in its short notice
we're asking for responses about August
30th at 5 o'clock p.m. he's going on the
world and at least they follow the ideal
space would be a human-made underground
environment spanning several city blocks
with complex layout and multiple stories
including atriums tunnels and stairways
spaces that are currently closed off
from pedestrians or can be temporarily
used for testing or of interest what
you know what they're doing there
they're growing Godzilla no they're
looking for they're looking for Ninja
Turtles fall out you know about a new
aliens are coming Luke's
so like we caught an alien he needs to
move around a lot we need like a
terrarium for him but he's like mousse a
lot yeah that would freak out about a
read that I would add it in law damn
delay which I work out doing doors that
locked me outside please also feeding
slots
thank you doing fitness losses is funny
you kick the metal train through always
yeah I always like that in my standup
the sliding gate in we follow food in I
miss jail like stranger things yeah
that's so people are connecting the dots
who they said wait is this for a Demi
Gorgon and then they tweeted out now
that's the Department of Energy thing oh
[Music]
please
Demi Gorgons are such a Department of
Energy thing Wow I want to hear humor
from like a federal agency I mean either
they should stop light years ahead
I've noticed that a lot of federal
agencies are pretty funny now like the
CIA is I mean they're hilarious
hilarious for a long time
hey actually there's some very
interesting stuff that the CIA has done
that is that is I think considered funny
like yeah I like the whole JFK murder
thing about hilarious prank but I didn't
see that going there
Frank bro no no that I'm thinking of the
the [ __ ] they were studying
psychedelics and [ __ ] yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah you had people in rooms and like
the men who stare at goats stuff too
like there's a lot of funny stare at
goats the men who stare at goats they
were trying to detect to test psychic
psychedelic drugs no psychic be their
shop blow-up phenomena by [ __ ]
looking at me exactly then I do uh the
sleeper sales program so what's that oh
yeah you're talking about jury and
candidate no no no he's talking about
what's it called the [ __ ] the movie
title and in Kristen Stewart when I hear
a second word or a certain
Manchurian Candidate is basically like a
spy or somebody that they they
pre-program and they psychologically
hypnotize and [ __ ] you lander right Zoo
yeah Zoolander and you do the trigger
word and then they go into their
assassination mode yeah ultra [ __ ] I've
never seen it well it's basically that
that idea like they're growing way
ultros not the movie is it it's the
actual program yeah that well it's
called American ultra but the movie the
program is that you creating like people
who will do whatever the [ __ ] you want
by mind-control actually did that [ __ ]
they say that they do that now with TV
and [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah they do the
government throws like subliminal
messages that we really can't catch with
the name Josie the Pussycats
the live-action movie how they were
putting subliminal messages well keep it
coming cuz I make I'm being really
creative how about not even subliminal
[ __ ] they have CIA agents all over every
channel Fox News CNN MSNBC they they
basically hire guys going directly from
CIA and they yeah and there are now yeah
right here
you don't know it how do they stop
themselves from just crazy guys
some more vocab you
yeah the cabbie me those glasses look
kind of CIA though bro
no okay now you look I don't want to
break that yeah someone tweeted uh hi
could you phrase this in a way that
scares the [ __ ] out of me at less thanks
well yeah a lot of people were replying
to this tweet being like why don't you
just check Epstein's island like you
know i just heard there's like this
whole island in the caribbean that's now
vacant oh damn that story went away
quick didn't it yeah what is that all
about talk about it no no man nobody's
really go started they just started
focusing on shootings that's all they
did
dude there was a person who was involved
with all the Epstein stuff who just
completely disappeared recently oh you
mean the label days ago yeah the lady
she was found at eating out out here no
no not that one oh this is another
problem I don't know if they were lady
but they were they were involved with
his operation and then they just
completely vanished oh wow oh sit damn
he could have got a lot of people in
trouble not pay attention to it for very
long he's just supposed to believe that
the official story does anyone does
anyone actually believe the official
story I don't want to see themself in a
Cell
after being on suicide watch yeah I want
to stay ignorant I don't want to know
you don't know well I'm addicted to
conspiracy theories yeah so I love
knowing I can't help it
yeah it's like drama like you can't help
but yeah you wanna know you want yeah I
don't want to know cuz after I know I
know too much it didn't I feel like I
have an obligation to tell the world and
then people think I'm crazy and I'm like
that
well they but they painted this crazy so
you know your conspiracy theorists
already even went back when Epstein died
you're a conspiracy theorist if you
thought that he actually didn't kill
himself like when they had just
announced it I remember I was listening
that NPR and they had a lady on and they
were talking about guy he's like I don't
think he actually comes I was like we
don't deal with conspiracy theories here
we're in PR Wow shutting it down real
fast
the news gets [ __ ] wrong all the time
you can't just talk about something well
NPR is very they think so you bag the
differ
well dude they push that I mean everyone
push that whole Russia story for [ __ ]
ever and there nothing came of that no
that's true nobody went to jail for
conspiracy or any [ __ ] they went to
jail for tax [ __ ] [ __ ] or well
Russia's story the whole like Russia
collusion with the trial government rump
and everybody it was total horseshit
story I even called it on Jay King as
two years ago and people like Steve just
regurgitating talking points and I'm
like dude no there's actually nobody
even being indicted for conspiracy which
is what you need but Steve I just want
to think about what kind of pancakes I'm
gonna eat tomorrow I know you make like
two real I know it's too scary and then
I I can't stop reading it that's why
ignorance is bliss man cuz you start
finding out some stuff you'd be like oh
yeah because you know what I really want
to do now is I want to become rich and
powerful to uncover all of that stuff
you know so I could be like I knew it
you guys were [ __ ] around this whole
time I'm gonna tell on you you
[ __ ] clothes without killing you
- hey this isn't even a right or left
thing there's a there's a left-wing
journalist named Aaron matei who was a
Pulitzer Prize winner and he covered all
this Russia [ __ ] and how was worship the
whole time and they basically
blackballed him from all TV he's not on
cable hold its drinks fake news right
watch Jimmy doorman Jimmy door is great
I love him he's a composite comedian
who's like does like political stuff and
he's a Democrat and he just blow the
whole thing out of the water years ago
yeah so back to dart by here so everyone
was freaking out and everyone's like
what what the [ __ ]
stranger things demagoguery and all this
all these things but there's actually a
reason why they are trying to find
locations and it's meant for dart buzz
subterranean challenge which is a
competition that seeks novel approaches
and breakthrough technologies that might
help the US military and first
responders navigate tunnels the urban
underground and cave networks so they've
already done tunnels they're working on
urban underground and that's the reason
why they tweeted that out for you know
private privately owned underground
course like an obstacle course to
practice on yeah so there's a more than
five million dollars in prizes Wow
and NASA's Jet Propulsion Laboratory
called it the robot Olympics so who all
is who privately owned sewers ooh whoo
turtles all cities yeah so it sounds
like my university owned or commercially
or commercially managed underground
urban tunnels okay so the commercially
poor don't like the is that for the city
because that sounds like a real estate
company they just gotta lick it was like
em and I bought these sewers cut em
block the bottom of UCLA there's very
complex tunnel systems and it's supposed
to be made if the president comes to the
west coast and there's like a bomb
threat he can go underneath there really
well why would people burn that out now
they're gonna attack you see it's hard
it's hard to find it's it's really I
know where the one of the entrances are
I've never been inside don't work but
you know what answers are you sure
that's it one of them to here where's
Tupac you said in the beginning the
video if you think he's still alive
worthy uh Cuba okay
oh you're saying you're you to [ __ ] me
no no I'm not by any means no Evans
though yeah me times a man got shot
those problems at all no no no no what's
your basis for thinking that uh he was
friends with Castro no no I said my
basis is when he changed his name and
what the name changed the two men yeah
and I figured death and like is it just
like the timing was so weird like a jazz
well from the writer yeah thing was a
writer and like all you had to do was be
gone for seven years right I think
that's that legally that's that's the
epic if you faked your dad she was gone
for seven years and then if you wanted
to have a comeback you come back and
Hamlet or just run up against you oh wow
but I like if he's chilling the killer
he's making a good life he still he
released more hours dead than he did a
life so he's probably getting nice
little Rory check you know why would he
come back
I see I want him I come back what do you
think I oh I would you so I'm sure why
not what's not
come on you know what cuz we need him
now yeah
we have loud now like the way we need
Dave Chappelle we need fun Spears's fun
spear Caesar that's why the moon [ __ ]
sponges it's so absurd to me but with
the JFK ones not fun so I'm like I don't
[ __ ] with as much mmm it's kind of sad
yeah I'm sorry about that one guys it's
not a fun spirit
[Music]